hello it's Greg Alda here and it's John
over here so we watch Blade Runner 1
very late last night but we needed a
little bit of sleep so yeah I'd be awake
for this trailer and that's why I'm
coming at you a tad bit late yeah
minimal sleep so we can understand 2
minutes and 15 seconds
tomorrow I am content every civilization
yes was built off the back of a
disposable warhorse whoa but I can only
make something good happy birthday and
very important to things
that's what we do here oh my god with
world itself on a wall that separates
kind
a lighter side there's no wall you
bought a war
ah
the ender comet your job once
good
I know huh what do you want I want ask
you some questions
- is it played off each other
the key to the future
is finally
okay
[Music]
you know you're here
[Music]
yes
[Music]
I always told you yes their story isn't
over yet you're still pagelet
[Music]
wait is he a replicant
I didn't need that tag then you see a
replicant I don't want to wonder about
that right now
to figure it every the same question you
ask yourself all throughout the first
Bladerunner hurt join the digital kind
of right has different rules so in this
one Jared Leto's is the makers of the a
droids I guess so alright well it looks
like he's doing a much better job than
he did in that one movie that we won't
mention I can't think of any movie you
might be done it was really creepy here
you know when we were watching the first
Blade Runner last night if I didn't know
where this got directed it and I was
watching that movie and someone told me
that the need is one I would be like oh
yeah I could totally see that
oh yeah I've seen three of his movies
prisoners Sicario and arrival the way to
tone this style they're kind of Darcy is
the word uneasy feeling that you get and
a lot of the scenes of how you know
first it was a rival being like a sci-fi
picture but a lot of them are just
really good character scenes filled with
tension yeah more like so the camera
doesn't have to cut all the time you
make deliberately paced games and Blade
Runner is definitely like a deliberately
paced movie that takes its time but
still gets played absolutely so I feel
so when we watch Blade Runner last time
we were like okay yeah then he's a
perfect idea to continue the Blade
Runner sequel and Ryan Gosling you know
playing a totally different character
but filling the type of character that
Harrison Ford was filming for the first
Blade Runner Ryan Gosling's
perfect for this - yeah Harrison Ford
has that Loki sort of not cool but
there's something cool about him that
cool dark loner character who's very
observant has a lot of in mind you know
there are some ports quiet and a lot of
things
he's on these are constantly running
Malfoy physical is a rather quiet guy
Ryan Gosling's the master actor I am
wanted guys can do quiet a period of
time can make looking at stuff look cool
but even so but even some of the imagery
here looks like Ryan Gosling's character
is probably going to be pushed to more
emotional depth a little bit more on
edge and Harrison Ford's character
wasn't the first Blade Runner
yeah whatever his mission is here it
looks like it's beating the hell up yeah
it looks it looks like one of those
performances is going to start off
rather calm and then he's just going to
be a little bit more like on edge as the
film keeps going even I've shown the
trailer Marana cops is like freaking out
about something I'm excited to see what
they do there but that one scene that
they have teased now the teaser trailer
in this one where Ryan Gosling and
Harrison Ford first meet that's probably
the thing I'm looking for yeah that
conversation and intros gonna be yeah
awesome
we go these two please love each other's
it is perfect like that wait yeah man I
mean like everything about this trailer
pretty much is really awesome like that
I was marking last night we were
watching the movie like that movie it's
still impressive in the in just how it
orchestrated the world and the city and
its gradual tone and they did all that
without all the crazy stuff we haven't a
so-so Blade Runner like really
impressive and this looks really
impressive like to look at like the
designs in the way the future world has
progressed looks dazzling but came to
mind me when you see that shot at
Harrison Ford of the snow is the force
awakens you know that's where they were
on a planet where it was all snowy
before he died that's gonna be Harrison
Ford's second death scene man I'm gonna
kill him off in the snow and Indiana
Jones fires what better time making all
the tables in his movies and killing him
in every huge killing him in the snow
can I use my Hollis they just doesn't
one hologram ever to be used if anything
so he just wants all the continuity and
Eva's characters dead which is this my
idea I think Ridley Scott once came out
and said that yeah Deckard's a replica I
think he wants us flat out set it and
said you know all the versions of the
Moon
leave it open to interpretation but he
said he's a replicant which it gets to
be curious that this movie takes the
route that he's a replicant the movie
says that they only have four year
lifespan to prove so did he meet someone
who was able to fix the programming
within him so he can last longer so he
could live longer or this when we take a
different direction where he's a human
being is Ryan Gosling a replicant its
Jared Leto I think I'm going to assume
Jared Leto's an Android who's building
the androids android building more
androids an interesting idea to look at
because it's Michelle yeah well anyway I
mean like you can't not think about it
because I was the thing dude I was
watching we were watching it last night
and I'm thinking to myself you know this
doesn't make stuff like ghost in the
shell look unfilmable
you know even background Blade Runner
was me in that movie it's been around
for a long time same concern as always
as long as this doesn't just become a
lot of cool images and I don't have any
reason expected Mike cannot then even
lose the great yeah oh really Scott's
producing this one he's not directing or
writing it but after watching alien
covenant revisiting blade rather than
seeing this it's like you he his film
that he's at least involved in or going
back to exploring the themes of creation
radiation yen and artificial versus real
yeah man intelligence and stuff because
the first movie you don't ever see any
of the androids being built because the
replicants are like kind of a lot you
know yeah maybe they are a bit adders
yeah I like a good birthing of
artificial intelligence scene that's
always creepy and gooey yeah yeah Beauty
and watching the uncanny valley slowly
become more and more yeah that was it
that was a cool imagery right here
one thing I'm noticing in terms of color
because I feel like the first Blade
Runner had a lot of the blue look
especially when you're in the city yeah
I hear there's a lot of that yellow tint
to it Roger Deakins instead of otago
field all the dreams of dudes three I
should an Academy Award photo it similar
to the way like fury road is just shot
incredibly and all the colors are super
vivid that looks like this but in the
Blade Runner
this is probably one of the things I'm
most excited to see now this year you
know I think the team they've got
together is amazing like I'm actually
excited to see Harrison Ford come back
yeah I feel like that could be something
interesting well I would have water
without if I were to hear like
Oh Ryan Gosling's filling in the shoes
for Harrison Ford I would have been okay
with that but it's more exciting to
having new characters Ryan Gosling cuz
it's like at the end of the day Ryan
Gosling's performance was a proven he
could fit in the tonal world of Blade
Runner and I don't think he's ever seen
like most of his films how these ever
done it sigh if I take this big never
Ananias fiction film so first aid
there's my video yeah there's something
kind of arguable but but yeah this is
definitely a sci-fi epic of different
proportions I mean it still looks like
science fiction not just like an action
movie which I'm happy about you know I
feel confident in the circumstances of
this movie that they'll be able to do
with the first movie then just tell some
sort of newer story and take their time
with it the only thing I didn't really
want in this trailer with that specific
code at the end where they're like you
there's something about you the remains
the mystery right I don't like I know
we'll do something questioning that you
know in this movie and I and I just
didn't need it out of the trailer like I
didn't want to get to thinking like the
end the same way
yeah this says look like an expansion of
the first one there seems to be going to
a lot more locations than they did in
the first movie - yeah I mean the scope
seems giant yeah it seems a lot bigger
but I want thing to is that the trailers
not filled with jam-packed of action and
I appreciate that it feels like it at
times though to me because everything's
edited really fast there's still one -
you turn up that way yeah thrilling it's
a beat you know I think they're doing
that for the trailer though hopefully
yeah I mean I could see you taking the
first Blade Runner and slicing that
trailer to look like an action thriller
when there's really not much action in
it so that's you break out the trailer a
lot of it is just totally good fiery
good man it is not like yeah grazie long
ass action sequence shot sir creepy car
chases or something it's just what
they're choosing to sell it on and I
don't and I think the movie to just be
that so can i I haven't used the trailer
for the original Blade Runner whoops
give me this I know but I haven't seen
that trailer so I don't know how they
pitched oh yeah
looking at this and looking at other
films of Donita I think that they always
are pitch like they have a lot more
action in them than they actually do
they intend to go that way because
that's what sells tickets against people
in the theater this is wanting to see
the big spectacle and I'm assuming when
you throw down this much money they're
going to want to see the best they can
it's open ticket I just know what a lien
has become and I just don't want that
for this and I don't have a lot of
reasons to suspect it might but you know
Hollywood's big machine it crossed my
mind anyway and dave bautista every the
roles I've seen a man that are not Drax
he's kind of just a quiet strong guy
hoping they give him an actual care for
her yeah I hope he's kind of like but oh
and uh goes for the show yeah all right
guys well you can subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification melyandd
notified every one of our videos is out
do it we recently launched the patreon
we've got that patreon community growing
over there to put up another video
segment this morning go check that out
check out the fun rewards Jon's reasons
to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram social
media manager and Blum house from the
real rejects how you and shout out to
ever Mendes those are not Ryan's
children I know this they're mine why
would you do that to the manager of your
heart the guys that you love because
only Ryan Gosling can raise my
biological children that's how it will
reach their full potential
yeah if I have children with Abe amended
and then Ryan Gosling brings them up as
though they were his very own good
looking is not nature its nurture